سعيد بانه يناقش المغرب ومعي بين الرباط
سعيدا العلوي وزميله صحفيه رياضيه اختفت
عنا لفتره طويله في الفتره الاخيره ويصبحت
ايقونه العديد من الشاشات ونحن نتابعها عن
بعد طبعا سعيد به ان يكون معي من تونس
فيصل شعبان وهو اعلامي وناقد رياضي وسعيد
بان يكون معنا من القاهره وائل سامي ورئيس
القسم الرياضي في جريده روزيل يوسف اهلا
وسهلا
بكم ابدى مع ضيفته من الرباط سعيد العلوي
كيف كانت الليله الليله الماضيه نمتي يعني
ولا ما نمتي خالص
والله حاولت انا لين الناس مسائيه يعني
ليله الامس ولكن مقدرش بقيت سهران الوقت
حتى حتى الفجر لانه حاولت انني نعس ولكن
الفرحه والارجنانين كان مرتفع جدا يوم امس
وبقيت ليله كلها وانا نشاهد في الفيديوهات
وعيد لحظات ضربات الجزاء الترجيحيه
والاحتفالات والاجواء داخل المغرب وكذلك
في العواصم العربيه والافريقيه وبالتالي
كان همم خاصما للنوم همم
ليله امبارح ولكن الفرح كان هو السائد
وحتى صباح هذا اليوم همم ترى الابتسامات
تتوزع شمالا ويمينا هنا في المغرب في
الشوارع حتى وان لم تكن تعريف الاشخاص
فانت تبتسم ويمينا وشمالا طيب بصراحه قبل
المباراه صدقت ان النتيجه ستكون بهذه
الطريقه
من رجحتي من الفوز خاصه نعرف يعني ماضي
المنتخب الاسباني
انا بكل صراحه ساقول بانني رجحت كافه
المنتخب الاسباني لانه من ناحيه كنت امهد
نفسي للخساره يعني حتى لا اطمع بشكل كبير
يعني واتلقى صدمه بنتيجه المباراه ومن جهه
اخرى لانني اعرف الامكانيات الفنيه
الكبيره للاعبي منتخب اسبانيا وكذلك
للمدرب الامريكي همم الذي
صراحه يعرفه الجميع ويعرف مستواه ولكن كنت
اعرف على ان النتيجه ستكون صعبه للطرفين
وحتى ان انهزام الناسف ننهزم بنتيجه صغيره
او بصعوبه لكن مع توالي الدقائق خصوصا بعد
ما اخرجنا من الساعه الاولى من المقابله
بشكل جيد واستطعنا امتصاص الضغط المنتخب
اسبانيا ودخلوا في الروتين ودخلوا في نوع
من الملل بتلك التمريرات العرضيه ما بين
اللاعبين ان
البلوكه الدفاعيه يوم امس كان جيد كان
متاخر وهمم تم اغلاق جميع المنافذ امامهم
هناك ادركت بان الامال همم كبيره للمنتخب
المغربي ان تمكن من المحافظه على الانضباط
التكتيكي ل- اا وليد الرجراجي وهذه نقطه
من نقاط قوه المنتخب المغربي في هذه
المنافسات هو الحضور الذهني القوي وكذلك
الانضباط التكتيكي وهمم يعني ايجادت الخطه
الدفاعيه
وانتظار الخصم يعني اعطاء الفرصه للخاص
اعطاء الكره للخاصم واللعب على المرتدات
او الكرات الثابته يوم امس كانت تدبير
المباراه همم مثالي جدا من طرف وليد
الركراكي كان هناك انضباط مثالي من طرف
اللاعبين كانت تروح قتاليه عاليه روح
وطنيه عاليه حضاره القرين من طرف اللاعبين
وهذا هو الامر الذي غاب عن المنتخب
المغربي قنوات اا طوال لتعود مره اخرى
الفرحه صراحه هذه الفرحه التي عشناها يوم
امس وعشتها انا وجيلي خصوصا لاننا همم هذا
الجيل جيلنا جيل انتيكاسات جيل هزائم جيل
الاحزان والدموع صراحه واقولها بكل صراحه
همم والدي دائما يحكي لي عن جي 86
والملحمه التي قمنا بها في مونديال 86
فكنت دائما اماني النفس بان العيشه مثل
هذه الفرحه كلها انني همم بقيت على قيد
الحياه حتى عشت هذا الفرحه مره اخرى طيب
فيصل شعبان يعني عندما نرى كل هذه الفرحه
في كل مكان بالنسبه للعرب في الخارج
وبالنسبه للدول العربيه والعالم في الداخل
يعني وكان الشعوب العربيه عموما خاصه ان
هذه كاس العالم فوق العربيه بحاجه الى
نشوه الانتصار يعني
نعم اخي توفيق هي بحاجه الى نسبه الانتصار
بحاجه الى الامل بحاجه الى الحلم بحاجه
الى هذه الرياضه التي تعتبر لعبه الشعوب
لتعطيها ثقه وامل متجدد كما
قالتنا
لانه نعم توفيق توفيق
المهم في الحكايه ان الكره ليست همم ملعب
واحداث لاعب ضد 11 لاعب في مثل هذه
المناسبات في كاس العالم اكبر تضارب همم
عالميه منذ 1930 في الاوروغواي الكره يا
سيد العزيز
هي يعني امر سياسي اجتماعي حضاري سياحي
وكل ما تقدمنا في السنوات وفي الايام وفي
الزمان الا
وتاكد ذلك
بالامس كان يوما للفرح العربي كان يوما
للانتصار العربي كان يوما للثقه العربيه
كان يوما للامل للاجيال الجديده العربيه
وهمم الحمد لله انه الكره التي
كثيرا في بلداننا ما يحتقرها همم غالبوا
اساس او عدد كبير من السياسيين همم هي
التي تكون هذه النافذه الى الامل والى
الحلم وما اجمل بلدا او وطنا عربيا همم
يولدوا فيه الحلم يا توفيق طيب سامي وائل
سامي من القاهره اكيد انك تبعت المباراه
بكل حماس اكيد انا حتى وسائل الاعلام
المصريه تحدثت الشعور يعني بالفعل كان نفس
الشعور الذي شعور به معظم
المشجعين العرب للمنتخب المغربي
دي حقيقه اييي
امبارح المغرب عيشنا جميعا في حلم جميل
وفي فرحه جميله جدا كنا مفتقدينها حقيقه
من فتره طويله يعني انا تابعت المباراه من
احد الكافيهات في القاهره
حضرتك لا تتخيل فرحه المشجعين المصريين
للمغرب اعلام المغرب كانت في كل مكان في
كل مقهى في كل كفيف في كل شارع عندنا في
في القاهره فرحه حقيقيه من قلوب المصريين
جميعا بتاهل المغرب المستحق واللي انا
شايفه حقيقه همم يعني ان شاء الله همم
هيوصل لابعد من كده بامر الله في المباراه
المقبله لان المغرب حقيقه بيلعب بواقعيه
شديده همم بقياده طبعا الكابتن همم وليد
الاكراكي همم الحقيقه ده درس في الواقعيه
الكرويه للمنتخب الاسباني ولجميع
المنافسين حقيقه محترم المنافس احترم
الخصم همم ولعب بعقلانيه شديده وباحترافيه
شديده والحقيقه عمل توليفه سحريه ساعدته
برده على تحقيق ايه الانتصار الكبير اللي
حصل على اللي تم على المنتخب الاسباني همم
منح الثقه للعيبه المحليه همم مع اللاعيبه
المحترفين همم بالاضافه طبعا لان المنتخب
المغربي بيلقى مسانده ودعم جماهيري غير
مضبوط من داخل قطر ومن الخارج قطر شفنا
امبارح المدرجات كانت اغلبها مشجعين
للمغرب علاوه على الروح القتاليه العاليه
اللي بيتحلى بها نجوم المنتخب المغربي
الحقيقي يشرفنا امبارح
وسيطر تماما على مباريات الامور رغم ان
كان في همم استحواز بنسبه كبيره
لصالح المنتخب الاسباني وده طبيعي همم
المنتخب الاسباني المنتخب مش قليل ومنتخب
مرشح للفوز بالبطوله
ولكن واقعيه وليد الرقراقي حقيقي خلت
السيطره دي بمثابه سيطره زائفه في النهايه
هو فرض اسلوبه فرض سيطرته وكان الفوز
حليفه وانا اتوقع ان شاء الله مزيد من
الانتصارات في في البطوله ان شاء الله
للمنتخب المغربي لان حقيقي يستحق والعرب
يستحقوا فرحه وكلنا خلف المنتخب المغربي
ان شاء الله في الفتره المقبله طيب ااا
سعيده بس بطل بطل توفيق نعم تفضل تفضل
تفضل تونس تفضل تفضل توفيق همم اثار اثاره
الاخوه واثاره الى هذا المنتخب المغربي
الذي يلعب اغلب لاعبيه في اوروبا همم لكن
اريد ان اقول شيئا المنتخب المغربي قبل
وليد الرقراقي
توفيق همم اللمسه وال- همم يعني الفارقه
اللي صنع وليد الرجراجي سنه وعلى المستوى
النفسياني لما تعود الى صور ما قبل
المباريات وبعد المباريات وتعامل وليد
الرقراقي مع لاعبيه سواء في التدريبات او
حتى في المؤتمرات الصحفيه يعني توفيق
تشاهد كانه صديق مع اصدقائه كانه اخ كبير
مع اصدقائه هذه اللمسه الانسانيه تجاه
اللاعب المغربي فقدت في فتره معينه قبل مع
اهالي لوزيتش شفنا الصرامه والحزم
المبالغ فيه وابعاد زياش اليوم زياش عاد
ولذه اللعب ومتعه اللعب عادت الى اللاعبين
ومدرب هو مدرب بسيط بسيط بمعنى البساطه
التواضع التواضع الذي هو من نوعيه السهل
الممتنع لاحظ هذه الصور وهو اا يعني بين
ايدي لاعبي كانه واحد منهم كانه همم وهذا
هو المهم هذه هي همم
كلوزيه لمسه مغربيه
ولمسه كذلك في كثير من الاتزان على
المستوى الكوري الكروي والكثير من الايمان
بال- باللاعب ولا المغربي بمعنى تصريحات
وليد الرجراجي قبل بدايه المونديال الى
الان هي تصريحات همم ترفع من منسوب الثقه
لدى اللاعبين وهذا الامر كان همم له ترجمه
كرسها اللاعبون على ارضيه الميدان هذا هو
الجميل في هذه الحكايه المغربيه والحدوته
المغربيه
للمونديال القطري ودعني هنا اقول باننا في
هذا المونديال قد فزنا بشيئين وهمم اذا
امكن ان نقول هو انجاز له طرفين الطرف
الاول لا ننسى تنظيميا وهذه الارض العربيه
التي احتضنت المونديال ووفرت لها هذا
الكم من الاريحيه ومن الاعجاب والارهاب ثم
من الناحيه الاخرى هذا الالتفاف وهذا
الانجاز المغربي الممتاز وان شاء الله
المنتخب المغربي يواصل طريقه بنجاح وهو
الذي موقعه همم ربع النهائي امام البرتغال
نستمع لفرحه يوسف السفري وهو نجم منتخب
المغرب الاسبق
همم جميع اللاعبين بالطاقم دياله دخلونا
للتاريخ من الباب والواسع فالحمد لله على
هذه المجهود لقاموا به وصراحه حسن كانت
موسى ان هذا كبيره ما بين الجماهير لكن
كنا نستاهلوا هالتاهل هذا مبروك عليهم
شكرا لهم شكرا شكرا لانهم كانوا فقر العرب
كاملين والحمد لله ما زال ومتفائل انا
ممكن نمشي والابعد حد لان عندنا ثقه كبيره
في هذه المجموعه همم صراحه مشكورين جميع
اللاعبين والطاقم التقني الجامعه والشعب
المغربي كامل لانه كانت مسانده جدا كبيره
ومن هذا اللعابات ان شاء الله مبروك علينا
كاملين طب طبيعه الحال تغيرت همم عده
مسائل اهم او ان تنشوفوا جميع الخطوط
المتراكبه وتشوفوا حتى الاراده والعزيمه
ديال اللاعبين خصوصا التقنيات ديالهم اللي
كانت ممتازه ولكن الى جانب ذلك
ممكن يقولوا الكلمه ديالهم اكثر
ولكن لحد الان فجد مشكورين على المجهود
اللي قام به وما زال ان شاء الله الخير
قادم
طيب سعيده كنتي تريدين التفاعل مع ضيف من
تونس تفضلي
ان مطرب الحي لا يطرب لكن هذه المقوله
فندها وكذبها وليد الرجراجي لانه اطربنا
جميعا صراحه ساعود بكم الى الوراء قليلا
وبالضبط الى فتره وحيد خليل وزيتش انا
اؤكد على انه لو كان وحيد خليل يزيد شو هو
المدرب الحالي للمنتخب المغربي لكل سنخرج
بفضيحه كاس العالم لماذا لانه قال حينما
اجريت القرعه
وتلقا انتقادات كثيره في بعض ال- ال-
المباريات الوديه كان يقول ماذا تريدون
مني هل تريدون مني ان افوز على كرواتيا
بلاعبيها وبتاريخها هل تريدون مني ان نفوز
على بلجيكا بلاعبيها وتاريخها وحينما
انهزمنا في ربع نهائي كاس امم افريقيا
بالكاميرون امام مصر قالوا مصر تتوفر على
محمد صلاح يعني خطابه كان دائما خطابا
هزاميا وكان دائما يستصغر من قيمه المنتخب
المغربي وكان دائما يوجه الانتقادات للاعب
المحلي اضافه الى التفرقه التي خلقها داخل
المنتخب حرمنا من زياش حرمنا من مزراوي
الذي عاد قبل مغادرته وحيد خليل وزيد
حرمنا كذلك من لاعب حمد الله بالرغم من
انه لم يقدم الاضافه الى غايه هذه الساعه
وخلق نوعا من الجو المكهرب داخل المجموعه
اليوم ولد ركراكي او قبل وليده قرار قالت
واحد خليل يزيدش كان قرارا جريئا من
الاتحاد المغربي بقياده فوزيه». وكان
قرارا سليما اليوم ولد الركراكي له تجربه
وخبره كبيره في الاشتغال في الذهن
والاشتغال النفسي مع اللاعبين لمسنا ذلك
بشكل جلي في همم فتره تواليه تدريب فريق
الوداد الرياضي كيف تمكن من تحقيق ومن
اخراج اقصى ما يمكن اخراجه من لاعبي فريق
الوداد حقق معهما البطوله حقق معهم عصبه
الابطال
الافريقيه واخرج من بعض اللاعبين الذين
كانوا دائما وحط انتقادات اخرج منهم
الكثير من العطاء وشاهدنا نسخه حكيم زياش
اليوم في المونديال الرجل انفجر تقنيا في
هذه المنافسات تخيل لم يكن يثق في حكيم
زياش كان دائما حزينا في تشيلسي كان دائما
همم يلعب بوجه متجهين كانت دائما تقاسيم
وجهه حزينه اليوم في المونديال عاد حكيم
زياش همم ديال اياكس امستردام يعني اللي
كان شفناه في اياكس امستردام وكيف كان
متالقا مع مجموعه من اللاعبين الشباب يعود
الفضل لوالدرجه على مر السنين كان المنتخب
المغربي او كان المغربي يتوفر على جيل
متميز من اللاعبين المحترفين لكن الهويه
كانت غائبه الروحه الوطنيه كانت غائبه
البعض ذهب الى حد اتهام اللاعبين
المحترفين بانهم يلعبون بدون روح وطنيات
تغيب عنهم القتاليه ويغيب عنهم الولاء
للمغرب اليوم اتضح على ان المهندس او
المايسترو ومن كان
ينقص المغرب وهو الدور الذي اصبح يلعبه
وليد الرجراجي داخل المجموعه
التجربه مع مدرب محلي اعرفها المنتخب
المصري لفتره طويله وحقق نتائج ممتازه مع
مدرب مصري هذه الظاهره تعتقد ان رجليكي
سيصبح المثال الذي ربما يحتذى به بالنسبه
لاكثر من منتخب عربي وافريقي
طبعا عايز اقول لحضرتك ان منتخب المغرب
تشعر كانه عائله واحده
بمعنى تجانس كبير جدا ما بين اللعيبه وما
بين المدرب فيه روح جميله كده في روح
انضباطيه وما بين التيم كله
ما بين اللعيبه وما بين اللعيبه والجهاز
الفني اا الحقيقه المغرب
درس قوي جدا وارساله قويه
للعالم كله الصراحه
وللمنتخبات العربيه والافريقيه همم لازم
نعتمد على الكوادر المحليه الوطنيه في
المستقبل المدرب الوطني همم الاكثر ذرايه
بكل التفاصيل مش لسه هاجيب مدرب اجنبي
يتعرف على اللعيبه وعلى مستويات اللعيبه
ويستنى يشوف تقارير فنيه من المساعدين
بتوعه المدرب الوطني بيبقى فاهم كل تفاصيل
الفريق كل كبيره وهي صغيره داخل الفريق
والحقيقه ده انا لمستها في المنتخب همم
المغربي والحقيقه انا حابب اشكر همم كل
القائمين على منظومه كره القدم في في
المغرب الحقيقه همم كره الكوره القدم
المغربيات تطورت تطور الكبير الفتره
الاخيره كره القدم بنسبه للرجال والسيدات
بالمناسبه همم نتيجه التطور الملموس في اا
في كره القدم المغربيه انا عايز اتكلم
كمان على ان المغرب همم خلال الموسم
الحالي او السنه الحاليه 20 22 المغرب لعب
13 مباراه رسميه
فاس فيهم جميعا ما عدا مباراه وحيده امام
المنتخب المصري في بطوله الامم الافريقيه
الاخيره بالكاميرون حقيقي همم حقيقي لا
نتايج مميزه حقيقي النهارده همم لم لم
يتعرض للهزيمه خلال المونديال همم
فاز على اسبانيا فاز على بلجيكا وكندا
وتعادل معكم دلوقت حقيقي نتائج مميزه جدا
كل ده مدرب محلي وطني همم ده نتيجه
التجانس وهمم
والتعارف والتقارب ما بين المدير الفني
واللاعبين احنا عايزين نبني على على نجاح
المغرب الفتره اللي جايه لازم توفر همم
كوادر وطنيه همم في جميع البلدان العربيه
المغرب على طموحنا عرب همم في المونديال
وفي اي منافسه
وعايز برده
بالتجربه السعوديه حقيقي السعوديه
طيب كسبت الارجنتين وايضا اا اشيرلي تونس
برده تونس حققت انجاز كبير برده كسبت
فرنسا طبعا لم يحالفهم سواء السعوديه او
تونس التوفيق وما كملوش المشوار المغرب
مكمله ونطمح في المزيد
حابب همم اقول ان المغرب امام فرصه كبيره
جدا فرصه تاريخيه في ان هو اا يعزز او
يستكمل كتابه التاريخ في المونديال همم
اذا ان شاء الله همم توفق في المباراه
المقبله وقدر يفوز وهو يقدر بالمناسبه همم
وهتبقى المكاسب عديده جدا همم منها مثلا
تصنيف المغرب في في الشهر في دي بقى هيزيد
النهارده المغرب ممكن يوصل للتصنيف
التصنيفه في الفيفا يبقى اليوسف رقم 16
على مستوى العالم ده انجاز طبعا ما وصلوش
اي منتخب عربي قبل كده همم بالاضافه ان
احنا همم المغرب
[موسيقى]
قطر حاليا
علاوه ان المغرب اعد رسم الهويه العربيه
والافريقيه في العالم كله
كان الاول
الماتشات بتاعه او ماتشات المنتخبات
العربيه الافريقيه بتبقى شبه مضمونه
بالنسبه
للمنتخبات الاوروبيه الكبيره النهارده ما
عادش فيه الكلام دوت والمغرب همم سبب همم
الانتصارات المدويه في بطوله كاس العالم
ولسه ننتظر منها المزيد ان شاء الله
ونتمنى لهم التوفيق في الماتش اللي جاي
بامر الله
اذا تريدين
ساخذ نقطتين من كلام جميل وائل من من مصر
النقطه الاولى المتعلقه
بالنهضه الكرويه التي يعرفها المغرب خلال
السنوات القليله الماضيه ما نره اليوم من
نتائج لم ياتي من فراغ في السنوات القليله
الماضيه سيطره الانديه المغربيه على
المنافسات الافريقيه ان كان منافسات كاس
الكاف المغرب حققه اللقب من طرف نهضه
بركان الوداد الرياضي الحقيقه عصبه
الابطال الافريقيه همم نهضه بركان حققه
السوبر الافريقي كره القدم النسائيه كذلك
تطورت بشكل كبير نظمنا منافسات كاس امم
افريقيا وتاهله الى المباراه النهائيه
وانهزمنا بصعوبه امام جنوب افريقيا سيدات
الجيش الملكي تويجنا بلقب عصبه الابطال
الافريقيه لكره القدم النسائيه كره القدم
داخل القاعه كذلك توجنا بلقب كاس الامم
الافريقيه
جبنا منافسات كاس العالم وتالقنا بشكل
كبير هذه النتائج ديال المحققه لم تاتي من
فراغ جاءت ب همم رغبه سياسيه همم اول من
يدعم كره القدم والرياضه في المغرب هو
صاحب الجلاله وساشير الى الفيديو الرائع
يوم امس يعني صراحه لم يكن احد يتوقع ان
ينزل صاحب الجلاله الى الشارع ليحتفل مع
الجماهير المغربيه مرتديا قميص المنتخب
الوطني هذه سابقه من نوع هلم همم نسمع
بهذا من قبل ولم نراه من قبل وصراحه كانت
مفاجاه كبيره ودعم كبير كذلك لاعبين حتى
اتصالات ودائما المتواصله للاعبين
والانديه التي تحقق الانجازات مثل هذه
الامور تحفز اللاعبين من اجل اعطاء
المزيد نقطه ثانيه همم متعلقه همم
لتونس اللاعب المحلي الذي
تفضل تفضل تفضل تفضل
تفضلي اتفضلي كملي كملي جمله
المتعلقه
بالمتعلقه باللاعب المحلي اليوم ربحنا
لاعبين محليين كذلك كان اللاعب المحلي
دائما مهمشان البطوله الوطنيه اليوم اصبحت
تنتج لاعبين كبار يستطيعون اللعب في
المنافسات العاليه وعطيه الله نموذجا
فيصل شعبان من تونس بالتاكيد تذكر تذكر ما
سبق ربما كنت تتابع برنامج على قناه
الفرنسيه الثانيه اسمه ساعه الحقيقه
لورديفيريتي وكان الضيف انا ذاك من قصر
مراكش الحسن الثاني عندما سئل عن موضوع
الهجره قال انا اعرف اعرف
المواطنين مواطنين بلدي المغربي لا يمكن
له الا ان يكون مغربيا مهما كان جنسيته
هل هذا ما قدمه اللاعبون هو دليل وتاكيد
لما قيل ان ذلك مهما كان العديد منهم ولد
في اسبانيا في فرنسا في كندا من بين
اللاعبين الذين القناه المنتخب المغربي
ومذاه ومع ذلك هناك هذا الحث عندما نرى
مثلا شعور حكيمي يعني يمكن ان نتسائل
التوفيق اذهب معك في مذهبت اليه وقد
استعادتنا الى مقوله شهيره
للملك المغربي الراحل الحسن الثاني اعتقد
بانه هذه الدماء المغربيه الاصيله هي التي
هي التي همم يعني همم هي التي دغدغ بها
اللاعبون العالم في هذه في هذا المونديال
صحيح انهم تكونوا في انديه همم اوروبيه
لكن عددا منهم كذلك تخرج من الاكاديميه
الملكيه المغربيه ثلاث او اربع لاعبين وهي
مشروع الرياضي في السنوات الاخيره في
المملكه المغربيه مشهود له بالنجاح اردت
فقط همم توفيق ان اتفاعل مع
المصري ومع
نعم واتفاعل كذلك مع
المغربيه بن سعيد نعم و ااا
هي سعيده وحتى لو حتى لو لم تمنحني الكلمه
يا توفيق صديقي العزيز حتى لو لم تمنحني
الكلمه
سعيده على الراس والعين والمغاربه اليوم
نورونا واعطونا هذا الفرح الذي سيكون هما
جدا للاطفال الصغار
ههه
ولا احنا نفس التاريخ نفس اللغه نفس الدين
نفس
الطموح الى الافضل فاعتقد انه همم ثم همم
ثم شيء هام في هذا الانجاز المغربي وهو
انه يعطي لاطفالنا وللاجيال القادمه زمان
في الكره في تونس مثلا طفل صغير تقول له
همم ماذا تريد ان تكوني يقول لك زي طارق
ذياب او حمادي العاقربي في الجزائر زي
رابح ماجر وبلومه في مصر زي الخطيب وزي
عصام الحضري نحن بحاجه الى استمرار القدوه
لهؤلاء الاطفال الصغار في الاكاديميات
وهؤلاء الذين يعشقون هذه المجنونه
والمتغطرسه وصاحبه المشاعر التي تستفزنا
بمشاعر متناقضه وهي كره القدم اردت فقط ان
اتحدث عن انتصار الانسان العربي في انتصار
المغرب تحدث همم ذلك الصوت القادم من مصر
همم تحدث عن ان الانجازات العربيه قد كانت
من طرف ابناء البلد كلنا يتذكر ان انجاز
تونس 78 كان بالشتاني عبد المجيد الشتاني
وتوفيق بن عثمان من ينسى خليل الزياني في
السعوديه مليان ساعه مبابا في العراق من
ينسى رابح خالف
ااا كذلك همم
المخلوفي في الجزائر عام 82 كل هؤلاء هم
مدربين عرب وذكرتوا بعضهم حتى يعني حتى لا
انسى همم يعني ونسيت البقيه ولا شك هؤلاء
الذين فهموا جيدا ويفهمون جيدا نفسيه ابن
البلد لا احد يحك يحكوا جلدك مثل ظفرك في
النهايه وهمم وحتى وان كان هناك مدربين
اوروبيين او قادمين من قارات اخرى بعضهم
يقدم الاضافه مثل ايرفيرينا وبعضهم كذلك
يا صديقي لا يقدم اي اضافه لانه همم يكون
يعني حينما تاتي به يمكن ان تقول جئتك يا
عبد المعين لتعينني فوجدتك يا عبد المعين
تعبان لبعضهم لذلك اقول لابد ان نؤمن
بالانسان العربي في كل القطاعات والرياضه
التي اليوم تدر الملايين المغرب اليوم
امامها فرصه كبيره ليه تحصيني مدخيريا في
السياحه هي تقدم وجهها للعالم هي تقدم
حضارتها مره اخرى للعالم والدول وتاريخ
الدول يقول انه لابد في كل مره ان نجد
انجازا ان نجد انتصارا يعيد الى حضارتنا
والى هويتنا البريق حتى لا ينسانا بقيه
العالم طيب وائل سامي يعني عاده الان نسمه
في كل التعليق بالنسبه للمنتخب الفرنسي
انه في لاعب يغير كل شيء على الميدان وهو
بابي
ولكن بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي بطل
المباراه هو الحارس في النهايه والحارس
تعلق بشكل
يمكن ان نقول غير مسبوق
النهارده
حارس المرمى ما بقاش فقط نصف الفريق
بالعكس انا بقيت اشوف ان او او اللي بقى
حاصل حاليا ان حارس المرمى بقى تقريبا
الفريق كله
ولولا تالق الحارس المغربي امس ياسين بونو
ما صعد المنتخب المغربي همم للدور
الثمانيه في كاس العالم الحقيقي
الاستمثال
والبراعه في التصدي لركلات الجزاء ومن
قبلها حقيقي كان سد منيع امام الهجمات
الاسبانيه وان شاء الله هيكون له دور كبير
في المباراه المقبله الحارس بيدي ثقه
كبيره همم لاعبته وخاصه
والعكس الثقه بتبقى متبادله ما بين الخطوط
ولما بيبقى الحارس همم قوي همم كل الفرقه
بتبقى قويه وكل الفرقه بتبقى عندها ثقه
همم
وان شاء الله همم اتمنى همم يستمر ياسين
بونو كلكم في المباراه المقبله همم
والتوفيق ان شاء الله هيحالي في المنتخب
المغربي بامر الله طيب هل انت صدقت مثلا
عندما رايت لاعبين اسباني بتلك الخبره
يعني اهدار ثلاث ضربات جزاء يعني هذا امر
ممكن بهذه الطريقه من قبل الفريق عريق
اصلا هو تقريبا في انزعاج كبير والفريق
غادر مباشره بعد المباراه لم ينتظر حتى
اليوم الموالي يعني في انزعاج كبير لانه
مثلا من كان يصدق
اكيد اللي حصلت حتى مع ميسي وحصلت معه
مبابي وحصلت معه كثيرين ولكن في هذه
المرحله بالذات شيء مستغرب
صحيح زي ما حضرتك قلت كل نجوم العالم قبل
كده ضيعه ضربات جزاء
في بطولات كاس عالم وبطولات اوروبا
بالامس الحقيقه كان يمكن تالق بونو وقف
حالا دون تسجيل المنتخب الاسباني ونجومه
اي قناه هو قدر يقرا اقرا كويس قوي همم
لاعيبه اسبانيا التسديدات رايحه فين همم
وكم موفق جدا همم وطبعا كان خلفه همم
دعوات الملايين في المغرب وفي الوطن
العربي همم زي ما تحرك احنا كنا قاعدين
على اعصابنا وبندعي بنقول يا رب وفي
النهايه همم الحمد لله حالفنا التوفيق
وقدر ياسين بونو يقود فريقه والبر الامان
وتصدى لركلات الجزاء اللي صعدت بالمنتخب
المغربي في دول
الثمانيه في المنجيات
طيب سعيده لا يمكن النسر في حاله الضغط
الضغط الدم لكل لكل العرب بالامس قبل
نهايه المباراه وحتى خلال التسديد ركلات
ركلات الترجيح ولكن حارس المرمى اكيد اصبح
ايقونه في المغرب اليوم لا
يقول اكيد
القامه في البنيه الجسمانيه وحتى شبه في
الوجه لكن لا شيء ياتي صدفه اكيد انه همم
ولد الردي والطقم التقني درس بشكل جيد
منتخب اسبانيا
وحتى في بعض الفترات في الشوط الاضافي
الثاني قد نلاحظ ان المنتخب المغربي يجر
اسبانيا نحو ضربه الجزاء الترجي
اسبانيا الذي كان يريد ان يحسم المباراه
هل صحيح ما رجع على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لان انا لو صدق كثيرا وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي
ركز بشكل خاص في الفترات التدريبيه قبل
المباراه على ضربات الجزاء هل هذا صحيح
الحديث عن المئات من ضربات الجزاء خلال
الاحساس هل هذا صحيح ام لا
حصل ذلك
وبعد نهايه المباراه جواد الياميق اكد ذلك
في تصريحاته الصحفيه قال بانه كان هناك
بعض لاعبون ليس جميع اللاعبين فقط البعض
منهم كان يخوض حصه تدريبيه خاصه بضربه
جزاء الترجيحيه حتى ترتيب اللاعبين الذين
اطار عمل ديمقراطي يعني مميز يطلب من يريد
من يريد ان يتكفل ورايت ذلك وبيرفع الايدي
انا انت انت راينا ذلك على الشاشه مباشره
لهذا طرحت عليك هذا السؤال اذا هو بعد ذلك
من تبرى
صحيح ولكن كان كان
هناك اشتغال على هذه المساله حتى التغيير
حينما ادخل لاعب بدر بانون لم يكن تغييرا
عاديه لان بدر بانون مو تخصص بالرغم انه
اضاع ضربه الجزاء وهذا مساله وارد لدى حتى
اللاعبين الكبار هو متخصص في تنفيذ ضربات
الجزاء الترجيحيه حينما كان في فريق
الرجاء الرياضي وحتى حينما كان في فريق
الاهلي المصري حتى ان يعطي ضربه الجزاء
الاولى للاعب الذي سجل في اكثر مباراه
ويسدد بشكل جيد ويسجل عن بعد ويسجل ضربات
ثابته هذه المساله كل هذه المسائل كلها لم
تكن لم تكون عاديه ولم تكون صدفه والشغل
بونو على بعض المراكز خاصه انه يلعب في
فريق اشبيليه الاسباني ويعرف جيدا لاعبي
فريق برشلونه ويعرف جيدا لاعبي الدوري
الاسباني هذه المسائل كلها جميع
السيناريوهات
واضح ها امام الطاقه ما التقنيه في حال
ذهبنا الى الاشواط الاضافيه الاكيد اننا
سنشتغل على هذه المساله خصوصا ان منتخب
اسبانيا منتخب فاشل في ضربات الجزاء
الترجيحيه
وغادر والمنافسات خمس مناسبات وكانت
منافسات روسيا 2018 خير دليل حينما غادروا
بعد ضربه جزاء الترجيحيه امام منتخب روسيا
هذه المساله كانت نقطه قوه لدينا وكانت
نقطه ضعف لدى منتخب اسبانيا حتى بسبب
الحارس همم كانت هناك انتقادات لانريكي
لانه اختار اني لاعب او الحارس ديخيه همم
انتقادات كثيره اكيد ان هذه المعطيات كلها
يتم دراستها بشكل دقيق وهناك همم مهندس
لهذه الامور يقف على الفيزيوناج او على
الفيديو وهو موسى الحبشي همم الذي كان
مهندس نجاح منتخب بلجيكا الذي تاهل الى
نصف نهائي كاس العالم في مونديال روسيا
2018 هو اليوم ضمن طقم التقنيه لمنتخب
المغربي وقام بدور كبير في فوزنا على
منتخب بلجيكا حيث درسنا منتخب بلجيكا بشكل
جيد واغلقنا عنه جميع المنافذ وكانت
النتيجه الفوز بهدفين للسفر طيب فيصل فيصل
شعبان لابد ان يشير بان البركه جاء
بالبركه بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي جاءت من
العارضه ايضا
ايه البركه جاءت من العارضه مرتين يا
توفيق كم المره الاولى في الدقيقه 124 اخر
كره في المباراه التي اضاعها اللاعب
الاسباني ثم ااا هناك كذلك البركه الثانيه
في ركله الترجيح وهي الكره الاولى على على
القائم ثم بعد ذلك تصدى بونو الى ركلتي
الجزائر اردت مع ياسين بونو ان اشير الى
لاعب بالامس قدم مباراه بطوليه واعتقد انه
قد كان قلب الاسد في وسط ميدان المنتخب
المغربي وهو رابط الذي كان في كل مكان
مرابه الذي كان اول همم لاعب كسب مواجهاته
يعني ما يعبر عنه باللغه الفرنسيه
لجميع وتقريبا دائما اللاعب الحاضر لقطع
الهجمه همم يعني كان مرابط متعدد متعدد
الخصائص بالامس وكان مرابط رائع جدا ثم
ياسين هو الذي اكمل هذا اليوم اليوم الفرح
المغربي وهنا دعني اشاطر راي الزميله
سعيده من المغرب بان اقول بانه لا شيء
ياتي من الصدفه في كره القدم باعتبار انه
بدايه من مرور الفريق الى الدور الثاني
وهمم سيجد امامه مباريات ما يعرف بخروج
المغلوب فانه ركلات الجزاء تصبح هذه كل
المدربين ولا اعتقد حتى ولو لم يشر الاخوه
الاعلاميين المغاربه الى هذه النقطه همم
كيف جهز الرجراجي فريقه كانت الجزاء فانه
منطقيا لابد لاي مدرب ان يعطي لركلات
الجزاء الاهميه وهنا لابد كذلك ان اقف عند
امر هام جدا وهو وقفه ياسين بونو على خط
المرمى نعرف بانه الحارس المرمى ليس له
الحق في التحرك زمن ركله الجزاء وقفته على
همم على همم خط المرمى لابد ان تكون الى
همم
الثانيه الاخيره من من همم وقت تسديدا
اللاعب ونعرف انه الحراس امام تمويه
اللاعبين وفنياتهم عاده ما يختارون زاويه
معينه
فمجرد الوقوف الى اخر امل للاعب في
التسديد والذهاب الى الزاويه الصحيحه هو
همم يؤكد استعداد ياسين بونو ثم لا ننسى
امرا هاما باعتبار انه الرميه همم الكرات
التي صدها بونو لم تكن سهله في ركلات
الترجيح وهي تؤكد ما لهذا الحارس من
امكانيات وخاصه استعماله لهذه القامه
المتر وتسعين سنتيمتر ليسين بونه وهذه
الخبره التي اصبحت له مع فريق اشبيليه
اسبانيا اسباني هذه النتائج في هذا
المونديال ما شاء الله
الحارس نابولي ههه السعوديه تفوز على
الارجنتين تونس تونس تفوز على فرنسا راه
اين المغرب ضد بلجيكا ضد اسبانيا هل يمكن
الان ان نقول بان المباراه ضد البرتغال
ستكون اصعب ام ستكون اسهل يعني كل شيء
وارد في كره القدم يكفي ان يكون الفريق
جاهزا لمثل هذه المباراه خاصه الان
والمسؤوليه اكبر بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي
هو المنتخب العربي والافريقي الوحيد في
السباق
بالضبط كده شكل المباراه صعبه جدا طبعا
مختلفناش المنتخب البرتغالي منتخب كبير
جدا
ويعجب بالنجوم الكبيره جدا ولا اسماء
اللامعه بس خليني اقول ان اول
المدخل للفوز ان انا كمنتخب المغرب انسى
تماما نتيجه ماتش اسبانيا
واغلق تماما اا ملف الاحتفالات والفرحه
بان انا تخطيت اسبانيا وصلت لدور الثمانيه
خليني اتعامل بنفس الجلديه وبنفس الروح مع
ماتش البرتغال وبنفس الواقعيه وبنفس
الاحترافيه اللي انا قدمتها كمنتخب مغربي
امام اسبانيا همم ثاني حاجه همم دور
الجهاز الطبي كبير جدا في خلال الثلاث او
اربع ايام اللي جايين اللي جايين موعد
اللقاء لان لعبت المغرب وانهكت الحقيقه
بدل ومجهود كبير جدا وهمم ومحتاجين ستي
همم اجهزه حديثه وعلاقه طبيعي محتاجين شغل
الفتره جايه وشفنا اكثر من لاعب ايه خرج
امس من المباراه
وتلقى العلاج بالخارج
تمام ثلاث لاعبين بالضبط همم فلعيبه
المغرب حقيقه محتاجه اعاده شحن بطاقتهم
للمباراه اللي جايه همم
علاوه طبعا على ان المنتخب البرتغال اا
سجل ست اهداف دفعه واحده بالامس نتيجه
كبيره جدا
اكيد اكيد طبعا المنتخب السويسري كان ضعيف
ولكن اا النتيجه نتيجه سداسيه نتيجه كبيره
جدا همم
اكيد همم المنتخب البرتغالي هيدرس مباراه
منتخب المغربي امام المنتخب الاسباني جاي
ده وهيعرف نقاط ضعفه وقوته عشان كده همم
انا باقول ان الاستعداد لماتش همم
البرتغال لازم يكون بنفس الروح وبنفس
الحماس وبنفس الجده وبنفس الجناعيه وبنفس
الواقعيه وبنفس الاحترافيه اللي قدمها
المنتخب المغربي قدام المنتخب الاسباني
بالمناسبه هم حارس نقطه ضعف همم
[موسيقى]
بالضبط همم
اقوى خط دفاع
طيب كل كلمه اخيره لك سعيده وكلمه اخيره
لديك من تونس
حول حول حول المنتخب البرتغالي المباراه
بين المغرب والبرتغال تفضلي
لدينا ثائر لدينا ثائر مع منتخب البرتغال
بدنا نسوي
بالرغم من اداء الكبير في منافسات روسيا
الطبي للمنتخب المغربي
متفائل نفس الشيء التوفيق متفائل بطبيعه
الحال متفائل
لانه هؤلاء الذين قدموا كل هذا العطاء لا
شك ان لديهم الكثير ليقدموه كذلك امام
المنتخب البرتغالي استعاده
الانفاس بعد هذه المعركه الكبيره امام ااا
اسبانيا امر هام جدا التركيز امر هام جدا
كذلك متاكد انه الرجراجي قد امر لاعبيه
بان بان لا يفرح كثيرا همم ويؤجل الافراح
الى ما بعد مباراه همم
البرتغال لانه اصعب شيء في الكره ان تحقق
نصرين وراء بعضهما ونحن معروفين يعني في
العالم العربي انه همم
نبالغ احيانا في الفراغ وقعتقد انه
المنتخب المغربي له الامكانيه
يا سيد العلوي وسميره صحفيه رياضيه شكر من
تونس لفيصل شعبان اعلامي وناقد رياضي
والشكر من القاهره لوائل سامي رئيس القسم
الرياضي في جريده رزل يوسف الشكر لفريق
البرنامج همسي مريحه للجميع